good morning Dom in a hotel in Phoenix
and I'm getting ready to leave this
section of the door and move on to the
Pacific Northwest will I be doing at
gatherings in Portland and Seattle and I
know what you people in the Pacific
Northwest are thinking you're probably
to get something like oh so you're
actually gonna have information on when
you're Seattle Gathering is gonna be
that's great but I don't exactly have
that information hopefully by the time
I'm ready to put this video online I'll
have more information but you Seattle
people and that will go right here it's
tomorrow and I have news about Seattle
the Seattle show will be at the Sunset
Hill Community Center at 3:00 0:03 North
West 66th Street Seattle Washington nine
eight one one seven the show will start
at 6:00 and it will go until 9:00 and
the room only holds 150 people also I
had to rent a room which I didn't really
want to do because it costs about $500
I'm gonna be asking for a $5 suggested
donation though you don't have to do
that but a five-hour suggested donation
to help me cover the cost of the room
now back to the other video I want to
show you some of the things that I got
from nerdfighters so far on the tour -
Hank and I also have a song for you
because it's on Wednesday running around
on a road trip is a really great time to
write songs and I have started to write
several of them on this road trip one of
them goes like this computer camera
camera chargers guitar phone keys I'd be
pretty screwed if I lost any one of
these so I wrote a little song to
increase my memories computer camera
camera chargers guitar phone keys funny
thing about that is that today I lost my
keys it wasn't my fault
I don't know where they went they just
evaporated luckily a group of
nerdfighters hung out with me and they
ordered me pizza and we ate pizza on the
street corner while we waited for the
locksmith so we could just make that my
song for the days that count feels like
it counts to me so continuing on here
are some things that I got from
nerdfighters this is one of my favorites
it's really in-depth the dream of
nerdfighteria I'm gonna have to scan
this and put it somewhere because it's
complicated space cow space cow ketchup
from in-n-out burger this machine poems
noobs this stuff is always nice to have
I got this balloon it's just best wishes
on it I don't think I'm gonna be able to
take it on the plane since I can't take
it on the plane anyway let's see if I
can make this a little more interesting
Oh
did it work it worked a little bit but
not very much shoot I
I really wanted to make that work hello
a my squeaky at all I'm not really I'm
very very slightly squeaky damn it I
wanted that to be cool
and it was mostly just lame dftba my
little pony anybody yeah uh-huh
dragon luck chain dragon e luck this is
a say that they come from the people
that you proposed to for them
giant P poster magazine bag got depth
and pants dishmachine poles doob dftba
what are you trying to say with this huh
this is pretty amazingly done pretty
good likeness
speaking of portraits this one is done
entirely with nerds you could peel those
off and eat them if you really want to
do this was a bunch of stuff that was
stuck on the back of my car after
Scottsdale another excellent and
complicated illustration this is a crane
made out of a bag of Lay's potato chips
notes on napkins nothing wrong with that
some excellent giant keychains a mule
disguisey kazoos all LeakyCon 2011
anglerfish I think that's all I've got
though I don't think that anyone has
actually seen this machine pwned noobs
on the video blog so I'm gonna do that
now it is it's totally legit and it's
got a tracklist and it's got that and
got this and got a poster poster pole
star a star power star foster Punk look
at me and then the back it's got this
amazing artwork by char guy and it
together looks because it's hard to
understand what I'm saying sometimes and
then this pops out here and then you got
that and then you got this stuff so it
works it comes with a poster I really
need to go to sleep now because I need
to get on a plane john dftba
[Music]